I had to do a fleet salient animal for constipation issues. The direction said to lie on my left
side. Your coffee animal directions say to lie down on the right side. What's the difference between
left and right? Well, the reason why they're having you do, they're exhuming that you're buying the
fleet animal because your constipated line on your left side is going to allow the fluid to go a little
bit higher into your rectal area, hopefully loosen up the mass that you may have blockage in your
colon. Your right side, laying on your right side, the fluid is more apt to get to the vagal nerve.
That's the stimulant that we want to do with coffee animals. So the general coffee
animal direction to stimulate your vagal nerve is your lying on your right side and then on your
back and getting it up. Now, again, my easy, busy way of doing a coffee animal is you're just standing
up in the shower doing the coffee animal. And I have said over and over again that yeah, well, it might be
a little bit better lie down and lie down on your back and then roll into your right side. So you're
going to get baby a little more stimulation of your vagal nerve. It could be more difficult. It could
be messy. It could be, it could make a person less apt to do a coffee animal. So I think it's best
just to do the easy, easy way stated up in the shower. It's going to be easier. You're going to be
more apt to do it and that's going to be better. So yeah, so whichever way you need to move around
to get your bottles moving the better off you could be. And if you have constipation issues,
there's nothing wrong with doing a coffee animal for constipation. If you already have an animal
kit, there's no reason for you to go by saline animal. The saltwater isn't going to really produce more
anti constipation benefit than just doing a coffee animal. If you're regular constipation issues,
do more coffee animals per day. You could do up to five a day. And again, look at my constipation,
know how or I think it's something to start typing constipation in the blog post. And I have
you know, a set of information that you should go through if you have constipation. Start off by
taking some magnesium at night. Then maybe some if you still have issues and you're still have issues
constipation by doing coffee animals, coffee animals would be the best thing for you because they have
the other benefits of the coffee animal. By stimulating your immune system, by stimulating your
parasympathetics, getting your vagal nerve going. But then, you know, still having issues,
then look at using super aloe, which is the Cape aloe products. So Cape aloe will help is the best
I think help for constipation issues.